all right so I figured the only way to
make this video worthwhile is if I talk
about the Dark Knight like spoilers and
all so if you haven't seen the Dark
Knight the short version is go see the
Dark Knight for the rest of you here you
are The Dark Knight all right so when
Batman Begins left off Jim Gordon gave
Batman a card he turned it over to Joker
cards here like aw dude the next one
Joker and my friends and I were such
freaks that we went up to the IMAX to
see I am Legend cuz if you saw the movie
and I'm actually got to see the first
five minutes of the Dark Knight which
was the bank robbery scene long story
short the Joker's men are robbing a mob
bank and they all start getting picked
off and then surprised the last one
standing is the Joker he has the mobs
money and he leaves and Jim Gordon and
Batman are trying to take out the mob
and they see the Joker's picture and
they're like how much trouble can he
really be let's concentrate on the mob
the important stuff is not like this
clowns gonna cause me problems you know
now when Heath Ledger was cast as the
Joker at first I was like I don't know
what to think then we saw the teaser
trailer and we heard the Joker
starting tonight people will die I'm a
man of my word
and I was like holy crap I can't believe
this Heath Ledger that he kind of sounds
like beetlejuice I'm a man of my word
but in any case I can't believe that boy
still came out of sir Ulrich von
Lichtenstein and when the first pictures
of Heath Ledger as the Joker came out
people were alive he looks like the
Joker but it doesn't look like he feels
like the Joker I can see what they're
saying it's the lighting of the pictures
he looks just like happy and fun and
then the trailer came out and we saw
this and right there I was like any and
all doubts are now gone if they just had
that picture of the Joker is like the
first official Joker picture known with
a [ __ ] but I'm at the movie after the
bank robbery scene the movie goes on and
I noticed you don't see the Joker for
like 10 or 15 minutes but if you really
fall into the story of it it's good it's
a really good story because Batman and
Jim Gordon are trying to fix Gotham City
they have a new da Harvey Dent he's just
gung-ho also he's like yeah let's clean
this place up so it's looking good for
Gotham it's like dragging itself out of
the wreckage of it's shitty damnation
Aaron Eckhart is Harvey Dent he was
great these are really good actor I
remember the first time I saw him was
the core and I was like look at this
generic dude and now he is really good
Harvey Dent and I suck you know and
people who [ __ ] about the Dark Knight
saying like dude what is this like a cop
show where are the supervillains well
honestly speaking at this point you
don't clean up Gotham City by taking out
the supervillains you take out the mob
they run the show and at a point in the
movie you realize even when the Joker's
not on scene you want to see the Joker
again but you're still interested in the
story you want to see the inner workings
of how they're gonna straighten this
plays out and they had a recasting
usually I hate recasting I can't stand
up Katie Holmes played Rachel Dawes in
Batman Begins and now Maggie Gyllenhaal
plays her in The Dark Knight but
personally I prefer Maggie Gyllenhaal to
Katie Holmes because Katie Holmes looked
like she had to sleep with the DA to get
her job and Maggie Gyllenhaal although
she was sleeping with the DA didn't look
like she had to she looks pretty good as
a lawyer in this movie like if you watch
The Dark Knight you try to envision
Katie Holmes saying Maggie Gyllenhaal's
lines it doesn't work so yes Maggie
Gyllenhaal all the way for Rachael does
and they had a point the mob throws a
little ghetto ass board meeting in the
back of that kitchen and they're one
step ahead of the cops Jim Gordon's all
pissed off Batman's frustrated Harvey
Dent's not liking it I'm sure but it
doesn't matter because this is the
strongest intro to a character I think
I've ever seen in a movie yeah yeah I'm
talking about when the Joker crashes the
meeting so some people will argue that
the Joker's intro is actually the bank
robbery I don't think so that was the
intro to the movie that was the scene
that kind of threw you for a loop you're
like oh look at that it's a Joker but
after that he just leaves this is him
going you know what masks are off full
makeup
which almost doesn't make sense but for
the Joker it does I'm crashing this mob
board meeting and I'm gonna let them
know that I mean business and I am in
control so what are you proposing it's
simple
kill the Batman and he does just that
starting with the magic trick the moment
he says how about a magic trick and he
slams that pencil into the devs and he
was like I'm gonna make this pencil
disappear
he takes pawns friend's head and he
slams it to the pencil and the greatest
part is when I was watching it the other
day you hear the splat of the eye before
you hear the thud of the table awesome
and of course me like everyone else in
the movie theatre I laughed really hard
actually which probably makes me a
morbid bastard the Joker is an
unstoppable hurricane that just lands
into Gotham at the worst possible moment
for the good guys the best parts when
the Joker has a knife and spawns mouth
and he's all like hi and this is the
part where he's like you wonder how I
got these scars and he gives this whole
story about how his dad was an abusive
[ __ ] and he gave him these scars and
I was like all right that's kind of a
forced story as to how you got your
scars but whatever then later on he's
looking for Harvey Dent then he has
Rachel Dawes by the face and then he
says she want to know how I got these
scars and goes on this [ __ ] story
about how he used to have a wife and he
put a razor in his mouth and I was like
holy [ __ ] awesome it's all [ __ ]
that's great I think Nolan really did
his homework when coming up with the
Joker for this movie it's about his
motivation because if you take the jack
Joker what was his motivation for
everything at first yeah I take control
of the mob and you can say oh yeah Joker
did that in this one too but then he
meets Vicky Vale and he falls in love or
some [ __ ] that's stupid the only girl
worth having in the Dark Knight Joker
dropped her out of window and that
didn't work he blew her up he ended up
being a hurricane of death and
destruction in Gotham for the same
reason pretty much that a dog looks his
balls just because he can and that's the
cool thing about this movies because all
of Batman's training revolves around the
fact that people have a point for what
they're doing and Alfred even tells
Bruce Wayne he's like as some people
aren't looking for anything logical some
people just want the world to burn they
don't care the Joker
one of those people he is not doing it
for a girl and another line in the
trailer that really shows where the
Joker is coming from is this
man because on the whole Joker versus
Batman thing the one way that the Joker
can really win is if Batman kills him
because he made him break his rule
telling you man sick individual
however if that's not gonna happen he
has his ace in the hole in this movie
either die a hero or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
Harvey Dent now Harvey Dent has locked
away so much of the mob in this movie
Batman Jim Gordon Harvey Dent they're a
pretty good trifecta of Awesome and good
Harvey Dent being the white knight the
best of all of them so the Joker's like
hey let's just turn him into a super
criminal that means I win Aaron Eckhart
was really good as Harvey Dent but you
really see that when he has to just
totally flip at 180 now the Joker
professes he's not a man with a plan and
he just does things but I'm sorry you
plan to get caught by the cops so you
can get mr. live out of the MCU you plan
to blow up a hospital which I'm not
going to lie that must have taken days
of preparation months even setting all
those charges seriously and you planned
to break Harvey Dent you are a man with
the plan Joker this city deserves a
better classic I'm gonna give it to her
so he burns and blows up half his face
and now we have to phase which I really
like the fact that they called him to
face like once in the movie because that
would look a little weird that in the
course of one day everyone goes from
being like Oh Harvey - oh hey two-face
so they just call him Harvey they made
his face look awesome dude this isn't
like some Tommy Lee Jones makeup where
he still has his lips I mean he's
straight-up like no no you're not not
yet I mean he looks bad I mean you see
the tendon right there it looks great
he's going through and he is wasting
mobsters and anyone who had something to
do with him and you know Rachel das
getting blown up if the coin says he can
wish that is one thing I find
interesting Harvey went from really good
to really bad he was about to smoke Jim
Gordon's kid mobsters are one thing
corrupt cops or another but that's a kid
that's another level of just bad the
long story short Batman saves Jim
Gordon's kid but you know Harvey Dent
dies and people have speculated well
maybe he's still alive he's not he's
actually dead I guess in the script it
says like he lays there with his neck
broken Christopher Nolan said yeah he's
dead so he's dead but this movie ends
words like alright if anyone finds out
that Harvey Dent killed people all the
criminals they locked away are gonna go
back on the streets which is really
funny cuz I think half the mob is dead
anyway but in any case Batman's like I
killed those people
that's what I can be so what ends off
Batman is public enemy number one and
the cops are chasing him and that's that
but there are a few loose ends in this
movie I mean that Coleman Reese lawyer
he knows who Batman is that corrupt cop
Ramirez
she knows that Harvey Dent was bad and
like killed people so I'm just saying if
I were bein in the Dark Knight Rises I
would go after the lawyer I'd be like oh
you know who Batman is I'm coming for
you although Gordon said well you can't
sweep it under the rug five dead two of
them cops I have done the math a hundred
times who are the five people Harvey
killed and who are the two cops you can
let me know let me know and you can
totally tell if you've ever read the
long Halloween Christopher Nolan took
inspiration straight from that so if you
really look at it when the Dark Knight
concentrates on the legal aspects of
everything and crime in the mob and all
that and people hate it and they say it
looks like Law & Order well it's really
pulled from established existing Batman
lore and it really works and I really
like the long Halloween in the end the
Dark Knight nailed everything perfectly
my only regret is they don't show
two-face that much he gets created he
does some things and then he dies that's
that I would have liked to have seen him
carry on but if Nolan's going for like a
realistic world you're not going to live
with that face without an infection
killing you The Dark Knight I think is
the greatest superhero movie ever made
they did my favorite character ever
justice they did him perfectly and the
Dark Knight oh cool
verse is awesome tacular so the Dark
Knight what did you think of it you
prefer the Heath Ledger Joker the Jack
Nicholson Joker comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more